Francine it looks like the man who
lifted the lid on hsbc swiss tax scandal
herve falciani he alleges that
management was aware of lacks controls
at its Swiss bank Francine great to see
you this morning as always for our
American audience who might not be as
familiar with this story sort of set the
stage for us what is HSBC saying about
all this well Olivia so we spoke to the
whistleblower of HSBC on Friday we had a
15 minute conversation now in the u.s.
last month because basically in 2007 he
stole data from hsbc private bank in
Switzerland he gave it to authorities in
France that then got passed on to the UK
but at the same time the US were also
alerted about this data breach and
potential accounts that allegedly were
for tax evasion so this kind of sets the
scene this was back in 2007 but then it
was brought again to the forefront just
a couple of weeks ago when the press
poured over this data and indeed not
only was it a breach but actually the
allegations that people were helped to
evade taxes came to light now I spoke to
him at length on Friday Olivia we talked
about Swiss authorities his day-to-day
life but what really jumped out at me
was that he is saying he told me that he
can prove HSBC management new of alleged
tax abuses frenzy I can prove and it has
to be explained you know that the top
management is aware and was aware of of
the problem that was was phased by
Geneva and private bank generally you
know I really surprised that top
management of HSBC are just pretending a
lot of things we're not trying even to
know what it is about they didn't even
try to get inside that of course they
didn't Italian got the ringer get from
from their own way to receive
information so I just want to clarify
because I did try to get out of him and
we're talking about legal issues felch i
needa clyde to identify any bank
executives he also declined to describe
his evidence he said he doesn't have
anything signed by top management but
what he says is he can provide logical
proof now you asked me what is logical
proof I don't know but it could be
something like
in the way the accounts were set up or
some kind of software Francine real
basic question did he tell you why he
did this was this just basic moral
umbrage at what hsbc was doing wrong
well it was so he's a very controversial
figure I did ask him that some people
say that he stole this for money
something that he absolutely refuses he
says he just sawed it wrong he kind of
put his hat on the moral compass that he
has and also asked him if he had more
data to leak he says there is more
information but he didn't want to dwell
on it again he doesn't really on the
focus to be on what he can reveal
further he says he wants a dialogue
between banks and also whistleblowers
again he is a controversial figure
Francine I know this is a story that has
a been across the front pages of
newspapers all across Europe and in Asia
in fact because of course HSBC is such a
presence in asia what is the bank
actually saying about this how is HSBC
responding yes Olivia we did contact
HSBC especially after these fresh
allegations they declined to comment on
fell Chinese latest allegations but they
referred us to the bank's earlier
statements on the icij now this I also
need to point out that this is one it's
a huge topic here in the UK because of
the election in fact in a full-page
advertisement shortly after the press
disclosed this data the HSBC co offered
his sincerest apology for the swiss
private bank discrepancy and wrote in
that apology that the unit had been
completely overhauled